BRIAN:  OKAY, SORRY.
AINSLEY: LET’S BRING IN
LOUISIANA SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY,
RECENTLY JOINED THE GOP
DELEGATION ON TOUR IN THE BORDER
FACILITY IN DONNA, TEXAS GOOD
MORNING TO YOU, SENATOR.
>> GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: IF YOU LOOK AT THESE
NUMBER, DEPORTATIONS THEY ARE IN
ARRESTS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN
THE U.S. HAVE FALLEN SHARPLY
UNDER BIDEN’S WATCH.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS LET’S
TAKE LAST DECEMBER.
THAT WAS THE LAST FULL MONTH
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THERE WERE 5,735 I.C.E.
DEPORTATIOIONS.
NOW, LOOK AT FEBRUARY.
THAT FULL MONTH, THAT WAS THE
FIRST FULL MONTH UNDER BIDEN
, 2,590.
BRIAN:  BUT JUST LESS PEOPLE
COMING HERE THAT’S ALL.
AINSLEY: RIGHT, RIGHT, MORE
PEOPLE COMING AND FEWER ARRESTS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
WHY IS THAT, AND WHAT’S YOUR
REACTION?
>> SOMETIMES WHEN PEOPLE ACT
LIKE THEY DON’T CARE, IT’S NOT
AN ACT.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN JUST
DOESN’T CARE.
I THINK HE PLANS ON ADMITTING
BETWEEN TWO AND 3 MILLION
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS INTO OUR
COUNTRY THIS YEAR.
WE HAD HINTS OF THAT IN HIS
CAMPAIGN.
BRIAN:  FUTURE DREAMERS.
>> TRUE, BUT ALSO, JUST LETTING
PEOPLE IN ILLEGALLY AT THE
BORDER.
THIS IS DANGEROUS.
THE BORDER PATROL TOLD ME THAT
AT LEAST PEOPLE FROM 55
COUNTRIES HAVE ALREADY COME IN.
STEVE: WOW.
>> PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD ARE GETTING TO MEXICO
AND FLOODING IN.
NUMBER TWO, IT’S VERY EXPENSIVE.
MANY OF THESE FOLKS WILL GO ON
WELFARE, PARTICULARLY IF THEY
CAN MAKE IT TO A SANCTUARY CITY
OR  A BLUE STATE.
IT PUTS DOWNWARD PRESSURE ON
WAGES, AND IT UNDERMINES ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION WHICH MOST AMERICANS
SUPPORT.
NOW, IN FURTHER EVIDENCE OF WHAT
I JUST SUGGESTED, THE PRESIDENT
HAS PUT VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS IN
CHARGE OF TRYING TO COMBAT THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THERE’S SOME CONFUSION.
SHE SAYS SHE DOESN’T WANT IT.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS SHE’S GOT TO
TAKE IT, BUT NO DISRESPECT TO
THE VICE PRESIDENT.
I KNOW HER WELL AND I RESPECT
HER, BUT SHE BELIEVES IN OPEN
BORDERS.
MAKING HER THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION CZAR AS I SAID THE
OTHER DAY IS LIKE MAKING EL
CHAPO THE DRUG CZAR.
BRIAN:  RIGHT AND BY THE WAY
THEY ARE SENDING A SPECIAL EN
VIEW TO THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE
AREAS OF GUATEMALA BETWEEN APRIL
KATIE:  TOBIN, THE DIRECTOR
FOR TRANSBORDER SECURITY WILL BE
THERE AS WELL AS ANOTHER GUY
NAMED ENVOY SANUGA, SO THEY’RE
GOING.
WHY IS IT TAKING TWO MONTHS AND
WHY ISN’T THE VICE PRESIDENT
GOING?
EVIDENTLY SHE WAS WORKING THE
PHONES OVER THE WEEKEND.
IS THAT ENOUGH?
>> WELL IF ALL THEY DO IS TAKE
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
AMERICAN TAXPAYER MONEY AND GIVE
IT TO THE GOVERNMENTS OF THE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE COUNTRIES,
THEY MIGHT AS WELL THROW IT IN
THE DIRT BECAUSE THAT MONEY IS
GOING TO BE STOLEN.
IT’LL NEVER MAKE IT TO THE
PEOPLE.
NOW, IF WHAT THE  ENVOY IS GOING
TO DO IS TALK TO THE GOVERNMENTS
IN THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE
COUNTRIES AND SAY LOOK, WE CAN
DO THIS THE EASY WAY OR  THE
HARD WAY.
WE’RE GOING TO SETUP PROCESSING
CENTERS IN YOUR COUNTRY AND
ALLOW PEOPLE TO APPLY FOR
REFUGEE STATUS IN YOUR
COUNTRY, AND ADJUDICATE THE
CLAIMS THERE.
THEY’RE NOT COMING INTO THE
UNITED STATES, AND IF YOU
DON’T DO THAT, THEN WE’RE GOING
TO MAKE YOU AN OFFER YOU CAN’T
REFUSE.
THAT’S WHAT TRUMP DID, BUT I
DON’T THINK THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE
GOING TO DO.
I THINK THEY ARE JUST GOING TO
TAKE BILLIONS OF TAXPAYER MONEY,
AND GIVE IT TO THE GOVERNMENTS
WHICH ARE GOING TO PROMPTLY
STEAL IT.
STEVE: OH, MAN, YOU KNOW, THE
BIGGEST THING ON YOUR AGENDA
FOR RIGHT NOW IN THE SENATE AND
THE CONGRESS AS WELL, SENATOR,
IS THE FACT THAT IT LOOKS LIKE
THIS GIGANTIC $2 TRILLION
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL IS HEADING
YOUR WAY.
THE BIG QUESTION IS WILL ANY
REPUBLICANS BE ON BOARD?
THE $2 TRILLION TRADE, PROBABLY
NOT BUT PETE BUTTIGIEG, THE
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION,
LISTEN TO THIS , SENATOR, HE
SAYS THE BOSS WANTS THIS DONE
FAST.
>> KNOW THAT THIS IS ENTERING A
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHERE WE’RE
GOING TO BE HEARING FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE AND I THINK
YOU’LL FIND THE PRESIDENT HAS
GOT A VERY OPEN MIND, BUT TIME
IS OF THE ESSENCE.
SO, WE’LL LOOK AT THESE IDEAS ON
HOW TO PAY FOR IT.
WE’LL LOOK AT IDEAS ON WHERE THE
INVESTMENTS OUGHT TO BE TOO
BUT THE PRESIDENT IS HOPING FOR
MAJOR PROGRESS FROM CONGRESS
BEFORE MEMORIAL DAY, AND WE
CAN’T ALLOW THIS THING TO JUST
KEEP DRAGGING ON, BECAUSE THE
NEED IS THERE TODAY.
STEVE: SPEAKING OF TODAY,
SENATOR, TODAY IN THE NEW YORK
POST ON THE OP-ED PAGE THEY TALK
ABOUT HOW THE SINGLE BIGGEST
LINE ITEM OF MONEY IN THAT
PARTICULAR INFRASTRUCTURE BILL,
NOT FOR BRIDGES OR  TUNNELS BUT
IT’S FOR MILLIONS OF HEALTHCARE
JOBS BECAUSE THERE’S
STRINGS ATTACHED TO IT.
THE WHITE HOUSE MEMO OF
UNDERSTANDING SAYS THE MONEY
WILL BE TIED TO HEALTHCARE
WORKERS GETTING THE
ABILITY TO COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU WANT THE
MONEY, YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE
TO JOIN A UNION.
>> WELL, LET’S GO TO LALA LAND
FOR A WHILE.
THIS IS NOT AN INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL.
IF YOU THINK THIS IS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL YOU
PROBABLY BETTER STAY AWAY FROM
SHARP OBJECTS.
THIS IS A GREEN NEW DEAL.
BRIAN:  YUP.
>> WELFARE,
AND REPIRATIONS BILL.
BEING CHARITABLE LESS THAN 10%
OF THE BILL IS DEVOTED TO
INFRASTRUCTURE, AND WE DON’T
EVEN KNOW WHAT THE PROJECTS ARE.
YOU KNOW WHO PICKS THE PROJECTS?
SPEAKER PELOSI, SENATOR SCHUMER,
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN.
NOW ONE NEED NOT BE CLAIRVOYANT
TO SEE THAT THEIR PROJECTS ARE
GOING TO END UP IN NEW YORK AND
CALIFORNIA AND BLUE STATES, SO
THERE YOU HAVE IT.
YOU’VE GOT A POLITICAL SLUSH
FUND, AND YOU CAN SAY AND MAYBE
EVEN BELIEVE THAT TWO PLUS TWO
EQUALS FIVE, BUT JUST BECAUSE
YOU SAY IT DOESN’T MAKE IT TRUE.
THE CORRECT ANSWER IS FOUR.
THIS IS NOT AN INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL.
IT’S ALSO OUTRAGEOUSLY EXPENSIVE
THERE IS NO FREE LUNCH.
YOU DON’T GET ONE NOW.
THEY ARE GOING TO PAY FOR IT
THROUGH MORE DEBT, AND HIGHER
TAXES.
AINSLEY: LET’S TALK ABOUT WHAT’S
HAPPENING --
>> NOW WILL THEY WORK WITH US?
I HOPE SO.
AINSLEY: THEY SAY THEY WILL.
>> I’LL DO OLD MAN BACKFLIPS IF
THEY WILL WORK WITH US BUT I
DON’T HAVE MY HOPES UP.
AINSLEY: THEY SAY THAT THEY WILL
, WE’LL SEE.
MLB MOVING THE ALL-STAR GAME
OUT OF ATLANTA BECAUSE THEY
CHANGED THE ELECTION LAWS THERE.
IT’S GOING TO COST THAT AREA
ABOUT $10 MILLION ACCORDING TO
THE TOURISM INDUSTRY.
I’M SORRY, 100 MILLION, AND THIS
IS CECELIA ROWSEY, TALKING
ABOUT THE ECONOMIC IMPACT AND
SHE’S A BIDEN ADVISOR.
>> IT’S A LITTLE EARLY TO JUDGE
WHAT THE ECONOMIC IMPACT WILL BE
, BUT THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
VOTE WITH THEIR FEET, AND TO
EXPRESS THEIR DISSATISFACTION
WITH THE LAWS.
THERE IS UNDOUBTEDLY GOING TO BE
A COST, I THINK THAT WAS THE
POINT THAT MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL WAS TRYING TO MAKE.
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL, WILL,
HOWEVER, MOVE ITS GAME, AND
WORKERS AT ANOTHER PLACE WILL
BENEFIT.
THAT IS EXACTLY THE MESSAGE THAT
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL WAS TRYING
TO SEND, THAT THESE COMPANIES
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE
WITH THEIR FEET, AND THEY’RE
USING THEIR ECONOMIC POWER TO
EXPRESS THEIR DISSATISFACTION.
AINSLEY: THE REASON THEY ARE
DOING THAT IS JOE BIDEN IS OUT
THERE, SPREADING MISINFORMATION.
SOME PEOPLE ARE CALLING HIM A
LIAR.
LISTEN TO CHRIS CHRISTIE.
>> JOE BIDEN’S BROKEN HIS OWN
RULE, AND NOW HE’S LYING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, GEORGE.
HE’S LYING ABOUT THIS BILL.
HE’S LYING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ABOUT IT, TO CAUSE THE
RAGING FIRE HE SAID HE WAS
GOING TO PUT OUT I’M VERY
DISAPPOINTED.
AINSLEY: WHAT’S SO WRONG WITH
HAVING TO SHOW A VOTER ID, TO
VOTE IN-PERSON, AND WHAT’S WRONG
AND TO VOTE IF YOU’RE MAILING IN
YOUR BALLOT AND WHAT’S WRONG
WITH HAVING SIGNATURE
VERIFICATION?
ISN’T THAT FAIR?
>> I THINK IT IS.
NUMBER ONE, I THINK PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS DONE THE COUNTRY A
GREAT DISSERVICE BY NOT TELLING
THE TRUTH ABOUT THIS BILL.
I MEAN, EITHER HE’S LYING OR
HE’S LOST.
NUMBER TWO, THE COMMISSIONER OF
BASEBALL IS MR. RON MANFRED.
HE’S JUST MADE BASEBALL A BLUE
SPORT.
BRIAN:  HE DID.
>> I DON’T GET IT.
I DON’T GET IT.
I MEAN, HIS ATTENDANCE IS
DECLINING.
IF IT WERE MY JOB I WOULD TRY TO
BE ADDING FANS.
THE ONLY THING I CAN FIGURE IS
MR. MANFRED IS PART OF THE
MANAGERIAL MELITE, THE
ENTRENCHED POLITICIANS, THE
BUREAUCRATS, CERTAIN MEMBERS
OF THE MEDIA, THE ACADEMICS, THE
CORPORATE PHONIES WHO THINK
THEY ARE SMARTER AND MORE
VIRTUOUS THAN THE PEOPLE THEY
MAKE MONEY OFF OF AND AS BEST AS
I CAN TELL, MR. MANFRED JUST
WET HIS PANTS IN DELIGHT AT THE
CHANCE TO VIRTUE SIGNAL HERE AND
ALL HE DID WAS MAKE MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL A BLUE SPORT.
I DON’T GET IT.
BRIAN:  RIGHT AND WATCH IT MOVE
TO NEW YORK WHERE IT’S EVEN MORE
RESTRICTED THAN GEORGIA’S
CHANGES.
IT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
HE DIDN’T READ THE BILL.
IT’S LAZY, AND IT’S COWARDLY,
FOR THEM TO DO THAT, BUT HERE IS
THE OTHER THING.
>> I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY,
WHAT MY DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS WANT,
THEY WANT TWO THINGS.
THEY WANT NO ID AND THEY WANT TO
BE ABLE TO BALLOT HARVEST.
BRIAN:  TOUGH.
>> YOU KNOW, THAT’S GOING TO
UNDERMINE THE INTEGRITY OR  THE
PERCEPTION OF THE INTEGRITY
OF EVERY SINGLE ELECTION.
WE WILL GO THROUGH EVERY TIME
WHAT WE WENT THROUGH LAST TIME,
AND IT’S JUST FOOLISH.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND, AND IF YOU
DON’T AGREE THAT YOU SHOULDN’T
HAVE TO, THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE TO
PRESENT AN  ID, YOU’RE A RACIST.
GO AHEAD.
BRIAN:  I’M JUST SAYING COMPARED
TO JIM CROW, A DEMOCRATIC
INITIATIVE FROM THE 1880S, IS SO
OUTLANDISH.
JIM CROW ON STEROIDS, JIM CROW
HAD A POLL TAX, A LITERACY TAX,
IT WAS A WAY TO KEEP AFRICAN
AMERICANS FROM VOTING OR
MINORITIES FROM VOTING PERIOD.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT
, AND, GO AHEAD.
>> I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY MY
GUESS IS, WHEN YOU GO TO PICK-UP
YOUR SEASON TICKETS FOR MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL, IF ANYBODY IS
STILL BUYING THEM, AT LEAST ON
MY SIDE OF THE AISLE, MY GUESS
IS YOU HAVE TO SHOW AN  ID.
BRIAN:  YUP.
AINSLEY: YOU DO.
STEVE: FINAL TOPIC FOR YOU,
SENATOR.
FOR MONTHS BEFORE THE ELECTION,
MAINSTREAM MEDIA WOULD NOT TOUCH
THE HUNTER BIDEN STORY, AND JUST
IN THE MONTH BEFORE THE ELECTION
, THERE’S THAT STORY
ABOUT THE LAPTOP SHOWING UP AT
THE SHOP IN DELAWARE.
NEW YORK POST BROKE THE STORY,
FOX NEWS BROKE THE STORY AS WELL
HUNTER BIDEN WAS ASKED ABOUT IT
BY CBS OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
DAYS AFTER EVERYBODY ON HIS SIDE
SAID DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT’S JUST RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION, NOT TRUE, NOW AS
IT TURNS OUT HUNTER SAYS YES,
COULD BE MINE.
LISTEN.
>> WAS THAT YOUR LAPTOP?
>> FOR REAL, I DON’T KNOW.
>> I KNOW BUT YOU KNOW.
>> I REALLY DON’T KNOW WHAT THE
ANSWER IS.
>> YOU DON’T KNOW YES OR NO IF
THE LAPTOP WAS YOURS?
>> NO IDEA.
>> COULD HAVE BEEN YOURS?
>> OF COURSE CERTAINLY THERE
COULD BE A LAPTOP OUT THERE
STOLEN FROM ME THAT COULD BE
THAT I WAS HACKED AND COULD BE
THAT THERE WAS, THAT IT WAS
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE, IT COULD
BE THAT IT WAS STOLEN FROM ME.
STEVE: SO SENATOR, NOW HE SAYS
IT CERTAINLY COULD BE MY LAPTOP,
BUT BEFORE THE ELECTION, IT WAS
NOPE, IT CERTAINLY WAS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
>> WELL, I DON’T KNOW MR.
HUNTER BIDEN.
I DO KNOW THAT HIS FATHER
ALLOWED MR. HUNTER BIDEN TO SEND
THE MESSAGE TO THE WORLD THAT
AMERICAN FOREIGN POLICY CAN BE
BOUGHT LIKE A SACK OF POTATOES
AND THAT’S WRONG.
NUMBER TWO, I DON’T KNOW WHY HE
IS RELEASED THIS BOOK, RIGHT NOW
ONE POINT OF VIEW IS THAT HE’S
TRYING TO SEND A MESSAGE THAT HE
IS NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR ANYTHING
THAT HE DOES BECAUSE HE’S AN
ADDICT, AND THAT’S AN
INTERESTING POINT OF VIEW.
I DO BELIEVE ADDICTION IT’S A
CRIPPLING DISEASE, BUT I ALSO
BELIEVE IN FREE WILL AND
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY AND I
DON’T THINK YOU CAN BE ABSOLVED
OF EVERYTHING YOU DO
WRONG IN THIS WORLRLD, NO MATTER
WHETHER YOU’RE AN ADDICT OR  NOT
OR  HOW YOU’RE FEELING OR  WHAT
SOMEBODY DID TO YOU, BECAUSE YOU
SAY THAT IT’S NOT MY FAULT, I
CAN’T HELP IT.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S A DEFENSE
IN A COURT OF LAW.
BRIAN:  DOES THIS HELP HIS DAD?
>> I DON’T SEE HOW, BUT I THINK
IT PROBABLY HELPS HIM.
I MEAN, THE IMPRESSION THAT I
KIND OF GET FROM HAVEN’T READ
THE BOOK, WANT TO BE FAIR, BUT
I’VE READ EXCERPTEDS AND SEEN
THE NEWS REPORTS AND THE MESSAGE
HE’S TRYING TO SEND IS THAT I’M
NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR ANYTHING
THAT I DO BECAUSE I LIKE COCAINE
AND HEROIN, AND THAT’S A PRETTY
DIFFERENT VIEW OF THE WORLD IN
MY JUDGMENT.
IT CERTAINLY HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY.
BRIAN:  BUT AGAIN HE’S TRYING TO
MAKE A PROFIT OFF IT ISN’T HE?
>> YES, HE’S GOING TO MAKE A
LOT OF MONEY.
STEVE: WELL LET’S SEE IF ANY OF
THAT STUFF TURNS OUT TO BE BAD
FOR HIM, THE BOOK COMES OUT I
THINK TOMORROW.
SENATOR, THANKS FOR COMING OUT